young fellow right here young lovin is a
set of rules that supposedly dictates
how you should behave you're not to
think you're anything special you
mustn't think you are good at anything
thou shalt not think you are better than
me you're not to think you can do to us
anything everyone knows what it is and
they know what they should do if they
want to fit in and they also know what
will happen if they don't fit in it's a
way of socialist stigmatizing people
that break the rules and maybe there is
something in that that has created these
incredibly successful societies
[Music]
I'm pretty sure there there is no
Scandinavian utopia but to the extent
that there is one I'm sure that Ianto
Noven is a part of it because what
people often fail to realize is that you
can't have it both ways
complete individuality where everyone
just ignores the rules and still have a
harmonious equal society it doesn't work
that way so you get to choose and I
think most people do the cosmopolitan
Scandinavians love to say the antal
that's something for the people out in
the provinces but it exists in every
city as well and that affects the choice
of cars that people buy it affects how
they dress it affects how they behave
[Music]
the British society has a class
distinction where you can do a lot of
things because you're Richard because
you have a background while Santa lovin
is trying to say no you can't because
we're a lot of people here and we get to
decide the rules not you alone
[Music]
Yentl all started off as a work of
fiction
I think it's translated as a fugitive
thank you a fugitive who crosses his
tracks as a satire on small-town
Scandinavia in the 1930s it was part of
a novel by axel sander Moser this is our
sue this is my grandmother
Harry's follow the mistresses
[Music]
he is my grandfather enables an author
he will see us drinking you know it was
not very nice to his children and wives
ladies oxen when we heard the men yonder
he called the town yen too but it was
based on new crouppen he thought about
the mentality that he felt there was
there and crystallized it in this
concept of yin to known anything you do
that seems out of the ordinary or
ambitious or not conforming would be so
punch by the community looking down on
that now he meant as a satire over time
over the decades it's almost become like
an informal Scandinavian ten
commandments the satire aspect has
almost been forgotten and people kind of
think it is how they should behave
[Music]
I want to do my own stuff
in my own way and not being like labeled
as an outcast you know like any other
girls yeah like typical illusions like
no you're not
I think it can become sort of a prison
because we don't encourage greatness how
many people would want to belong to a
vision like that
[Music]
no flaw is something I were stuck with
inside of us
I think this hill was there that kind of
way of thought may well simply be so
deeply embedded maybe it won't go away
the interesting thing I think is that
every society has those social stigmas
the great thing about Yount alone is it
forces you to think about what those
unspoken rules might be that govern your
life and so there's the first road to
freedom and and getting away from those
rules what you should do is choose those
that make the better society and those
aren't the Lava that we have which is
that you shouldn't think you're better
than everyone else is probably the best
way of organizing a society
you